estos sepultureros de sao paulo se
quedaron sin horas de sol y deben
continuar su trabajo a la luz de una
lámpara
brasil tiene el número de muertes
diarias por kobe 19 más alto del mundo
ya ha superado los 4 mil decesos en dos
jornadas distintas
en los barrios pobres de río de janeiro
el trabajo se acumula para los
paramédicos
ya me puedo imaginar mis pulmones
completamente bloqueados me da miedo ir
al hospital y terminar en cuidados
intensivos la ocupación de las luces
supera al 90% en la mayoría de estados
estamos en plena tercera ola y las
llamadas que recibimos se han triplicado
nunca se acaba no tenemos más espacio
muchas gracias
mientras los casos de la variante
brasileña se disparan el presidente
defiende su estrategia no habrá
cuarentena nacional y el ejército no
saldrá a las calles a obligar a la gente
a quedarse en casa estáticas el virus
sigue golpeando la economía cada vez más
gente hace fila en las cocinas
comunitarias
no podemos seguir mendigando al menos
tenemos una comida diaria brasil tiene
más de 353 mil muertes por kobe 19 un
total sólo superado por eeuu